this is the jiujitsu Kaizen Iceberg it
consists of seven parts and is full of
interesting theories and fun facts about
the show the first stage of the iceberg
contains mostly well-known popular
theories you probably heard of before
but as we go deeper down the iceberg the
theories are slowly going to get more
and more bizarre until they completely
blow your mind and let's start with a
really simple one the moon Theory same
as most other animes Jujitsu kaisen has
a lot of symbolism in it specifically
linked to Buddhism one symbol commonly
seen in the anime is a full moon and
every time we see it there's a
significant event that takes place in
Buddhism a full moon represents birth
and the first time we see a full moon is
when Yuji eats the first finger
symbolizing sua's birth in season 2 we
see the full moon again on the day Rico
and Tena we're supposed to merge the
concept of merging here is also
considered a rebirth confirming the moon
Theory the legend of Rian sukuna
although you most likely first heard the
name realan sukuna in Jujitsu kaizen's
anime you may be surprised if find out
that he was actually a real person who
existed in Japan's history and was later
made out to be a myth according to the
legend Suka the Two-Face spirit is a
strange being possessing four arms and
two faces he was described as quick
witty and possessing superhuman strength
he was considered by most people to be
truly heroic having a kind heart and
saving villagers from harm however in
some places he's known to be cruel and
evil always torturing people and taking
pride in killing them considering this
and the fact that he has two fa it's
most likely that suca has two
personalities within him one good and
one evil next up we have a mystery entry
on the iceberg and it's the one I'm sure
most of you guys will love honai star
rail okay this is definitely not a
jiujitsu theory but if you're an anime
fan let me tell you why this game is a
must playay honkai star rail is a space
fantasy RPG that's made by the creators
of genin impact which is already a good
enough reason to download it but if that
didn't convince you the game had over 80
million downloads within the first 6
months which is honestly a lot of
downloads with their newest update there
are two new limited five-star characters
you can collect huoh hoo and argant
argant is this nightl looking dude with
exceptional AOE attacks but the one I'm
really excited for that will be coming
out soon is HOH hoo she's this
overpowered support type character who
can restore teammates health and give
them cool Buffs man I really hope I get
her soon she would definitely help with
my losing streak this is the best time
to start playing Hye starwell as the big
1.5 update is out now you can complete
ghost busting missions explore a brand
new map and even get 10 free special
passes if you log in for 7 Days click my
link in the description to download H
Kai star rail for free and you can even
use my special promo code to get 50
Stellar Jades gagay hates Gojo during a
popularity poll gagay specifically
mentioned that he doesn't like Gojo as a
character apparently it's because he
made Gojo way too powerful and now is
struggling to come up with situations
and villains that are actually
threatening to the strongest sorcerer I
mean I guess he eventually found a way
to make it work the cursed energy cursed
energy is the main power system in the
jjk but have you ever noticed that it's
quite similar to the power system of
another popular shown in anime I'm
talking about hunter hunter in the world
of this anime there's a technique called
nen which pretty much allows people to
harness their life energy it's a
defining feature of yoshiro togashi's
manga and plays a crucial role in its
narrative interestingly there's a
fascinating connection between Nan and
the cursed energy from Jujitsu kaisen
here are some of them both require
rigorous training in order to use both
are inaccessible to the average person
and they share striking visual
similarities nanami original role
currently Kendo nanami is one of the
good guys but it wasn't always supposed
to be like that apparently gig had
originally planned to make nanami a
villain but scrapped the idea at some
point I'm glad this guy is now on the
good side just imagine how terrifying he
would be as a villain okay most of these
theories and facts so far are pretty
simple and well-known but we now enter
the second stage and here's where things
start to get interesting Gojo's words to
ghetto in the jiujitsu Kaizen movie
suguru ghetto gets badly beaten by UTA
and his near death when Gojo finds him
at that time Gojo sits down and says
something to him that we don't get to
hear but we know that ghetto replies
with you should at least curse me in the
end implying that Gojo said something
nice to him anyway there's spin many
theories about what he might have said
but the most promising one is that he
said we'll meet again but what proof do
I have of this well the first AR of the
second season is all about Gojo's and
ghetto past is the students at jiujitsu
high the opening for that Arc is called
AOS suuma and the lyrics are written
from Gojo's point of view the reason I'm
mentioning this is because there are a
few lines in this song that hint Gojo's
last words to ghetto the words to curse
you have been stuck in the back of my
throat we'll meet again right a voice
that can't be heard this perfectly ties
in with ghetto response and everything
that happened in that scene Yu gift one
of the Cullen game players yosu is a
powerful jiujitsu sorcerer from the hyen
era who was incarnated into the body of
mum's sister back in her first life she
had a very unhealthy obsession with
sucanat and near her death she we gave
him a mysterious final gift although we
have no idea what she gave him there is
a great theory about it a lot of fans
believe she probably created one of his
weapons from the hayan era more
specifically the spear that he holds
every time his original form is
mentioned this would make sense
considering Yu's curse technique is
called construction and allows her to
make pretty much anything she wants if
this is the case we should be seeing
sua's original weapon pretty soon as his
battle against Sorcerers is heating up
kaku's manipulation immediately after
Kaku managed to seal goj using the
prison realm the Box fell to the ground
with great force and couldn't be moved
at that point in time there was nothing
unusual with this and Kaku explained it
by saying that the prison realm just
needed some time to process Gojo's
Incredible strength but what if this was
a lie a lot of fans speculate that Kaku
used his gravity manipulation power to
do this on purpose and make it seem like
the prison realm can't be moved but why
would he do this well at that point
kinjaku didn't need the special grade
curses anymore since Gojo was already
sealed so it's possible that he just
needed a reason to stay behind while all
the other curses would go and fight
Sorcerers he probably just wanted to
exhaust the curses as much as possible
so he could easily absorb them later
which is exactly what he did with mjo
after the ladder was defeated by eug and
Toto Gojo's design you probably noticed
how Gojo's design looks a bit different
in the movie Ziro compared to the rest
of the Jujutsu Kaizen although the movie
came out between the first and second
seasons of the show The Source material
for the movie was actually created way
before the first chapter of the manga
this is why Gojo looks a bit different
as it was the first time the Creator
tried to draw him he later realized that
drawing bandages over Gojo's eyes is
pretty timeconsuming and decided to
change it to a regular blindfold later
on mantis shrimp black flash black flash
is a phenomenon in the jiujitsu kaisen
world that gives a major boost to
physical attacks when the conditions are
met when the user applies cursed energy
exactly 1 millionth of a second after
the physical hit it distorts the space
causing the cursed energy to increase
the power of the attack by two to three
times okay you all knew that but did you
know that this ridiculously overpowered
technique is based on real life
occurrences men shrimps are small
alien-like creatures that can snap their
claws together so fast they form a small
vacuum bubble in the water this causes
them to produce a force so strong that
they could never achieve by simply
pinching the target using this weird
technique the shrimp can even break
glass fish tanks it's most likely that
gay akutami the Creator jiujitsu kaisen
was inspired by these creatures and
modeled black flash after this technique
hak's domain hakati is a third-year
student at ji Jitsu high and is known to
be incredibly powerful to the point that
even Gojo said that hakati could rival
his power in the future regarding his
domain expansion it's inspired by the
Japanese slot game called Pinko
basically with each jackpot hakati hits
he gains unlimited cursed energy for a
short period of time making him
literally Invincible however many fans
believe that his domain is actually
rigged in his favor this is because the
binko game hakati plays heavily relies
on luck and it's even stated that
there's only a 1 in 239 chance of him
hitting the jackpot I know there's a
bunch of stuff he uses to increase those
odds but still haati just keeps hitting
the jackpot over and over again which
makes it really hard to believe that
it's legit I mean it's either somehow
rigged in his favor or the guy is the
luckiest person on the planet Tan's
gender Master Tangen is one of the
oldest jiujitsu Sorcerers in the series
responsible for all the barriers
surrounding Japan although everyone
assumes tenen is a man it was actually
revealed that their original form before
they evolved was that of a woman Tangen
even corrects Yuki when they meet and
tells her that she's a granny two stages
are now done but there are still five
left to go and let's start the next
stage with a theory I'm sure most of you
didn't know about his birth in the jiutu
Kaizen World twins are considered taboo
is beli that twins limit each other's
ability to thrive and that they're
pretty much an incomplete version of
themselves take Ma and Maki for example
ma was born with the weak curse
technique while Maki got insane strength
but without the curse technique all in
all they were both pretty weak by
themselves however when Ma sacrificed
herself for Maki she became incredibly
powerful and was finally able to utilize
her full strength so what if this is the
same thing that granted sua his immense
power you see there's a theory that sua
was actually going to be a twin but
ended up consuming the other twin in the
womb this is how he managed to become
ridiculously powerful and would also
make sense why he has four arms and two
faces this would also explain his thirst
for human flesh in the jiutu Kaizen
series raia's past you all know raia
from the jiujitsu kaisen movie as this
sweet and innocent girl but what if
that's all an act although the movie
didn't tell us anything specific about
her childhood gay actually shared some
concerning information about ra and her
manga profile here it says that Ra's mom
died suddenly from unknown causes when
Ra was five sometimes after that she and
her father mysteriously got lost while
mountain climbing and only Ra was found
she was later Taken in by her
grandmother who strongly believes Rea
killed both of her parents although
there's no way to confirm if ra actually
killed her parents or not this dark side
of her personality could explain why she
became such a powerful curse the first
calling game the culling game is one of
the arcs of the jiujitsu kaisen manga
and it's basically a deadly tournament
almost every anime has a tournament Arc
but nothing quite as deadly and
complicated as this one in jjk anyway at
the moment can jaku is the one who
initiated this wicked battle but there's
a really good theory that this isn't the
first time the Cullen game took place in
chapter 173 we're introduced to druv a
jiujitsu sorcerer from the past he's a
really old skilled Sorcerer And is
referred to as the veteran in his second
Incarnation this seems a bit strange and
it implies that he was incarnated once
before possibly in the first calling
game another thing to note is that Dr
was so powerful back in his time that he
single-handedly conquered Japan during
the Civil War of w which happened almost
2,000 years years ago meaning that he
was alive back then it's possible that
Dro was incarnated a thousand years ago
during the hyen era and that's when the
first culling game took place Suk paper
cut in chapter 216 suuk engulfs himself
in curses in order to get full control
of mum's body but when he comes out he
notices something weird there's a
scratch on his finger seemingly a paper
cut although the cut is small the manga
panel made it seem super important so
what does it mean well Suk is known to
have one of the best regenerative
capabilities of the jiujitsu Ka world
the guy managed to heal yuji's blown up
hands in season 1 and even managed to
bring him back to life so why was there
still a scratch on him the only fight Su
had in mum's body at that point was
against Yuji and Maki so it makes sense
that one of them did some kind of
irreparable damage to him this person is
most likely Yuji and there's a great
theory that explores this if we take a
look back in season 1 Gojo mentions that
Yuji will be able to use sua's curse
techniques at some point and it'll be
engraved into him judging by this it's
possible that Yugi subconsciously used
cleave one of sua's techniques to
inflict damage on him to be fair it
could also be that this cut was mum's
way of showing resistance against the
king of curses because at that point
sugana still didn't have full control of
his body I don't know about you but I
definitely like the Yuji Theory more
sua's curse technique so far in the
manga sua's curse technique hasn't been
fully revealed but there's some hints at
what it may be during his fight against
Joo suguna chanted the word open which
granted him Firebase powers from this we
could just assume the sugus technique
has something to do with fire but that
would be kind of underwhelming for the
king of curses so let's look at some
more interesting theories first of all
if we take a look at chapter 219 we can
see that the people in the hayan era
worshiped sugna like he was some kind of
deity and would also do rituals for him
also if you pay close attention to sug
mevolent Shrine you'll notice that it's
actually more of a fatory a place where
ancient artifacts are stored when you
combine these things together it makes
sense that suguna has somehow stolen
techniques from his worshippers back in
the hayan era and kept them in his
Shrine so every time he chance the word
open he accesses it and chooses which
curse technique he wants to use this
means that suca has multiple techniques
that is convenience and can use
different techniques whenever he wants
to if this Theory turns out to be true
it would be really cool to see sugna
fight using a bunch of different
abilities the real Iron Mountain did you
ever wonder how joo's domain coffin of
the Iron Mountain got its name as it
turns out it's not inspired by anything
in the real world but instead its
Origins can be traced back to ancient
Indian cosmology there it was believed
believe that nine mountains and eight
Seas Encompass the world with one
massive mountain in the center this
Central mountain is surrounded by eight
rings of mountains and the last string
is said to be made of iron this most
likely served as the inspiration for the
concept of the coffin of the Iron
Mountain in the series it's completely
insane that gay thought of this when
naming joo's technique but this is still
nothing compared to some of the stuff
we're going to talk about in the fourth
stage suca the disgraced one when we
were first introduced to suca he was
always referred to as the king of curses
however later on in the story angel
started referring to him as the
disgraced one why is that well looking
at suk's appearance especially his real
body the guy has two faces in four arms
which is obviously a bit weird the only
other sorcerer who looks nothing like a
regular human is Master tengen if you
compare their designs you'll notice that
they both have four eyes aligned in a
similar way and even kenju commented
once on how similar Tangen was looking
to sugana is this really a coincidence
the theory here states that the reason
tangan and sua have similar appearances
is because they both evolved when SU
going to evolved he pretty much lost his
humanity and the ability to show any
emotions this could be the reason why
Angel refers to him as the disgraced one
as he chose power over Humanity another
thing supporting this theory is the fact
that suguna always refers to humans and
curses as if they're below him hinting
that he may be evolved and doesn't
consider himself to be either human or
curse Yugi can swap Souls the whole
theory about Yuji switching bodies stems
from this one page in chapter 222 here
we can see Yuji talking to kusakabe and
referring to him as Yuji pretty weird
right so if this is some kind of Soul
swap technique how did Yuji even learn
it first of all in chapter 220 choso
gives Yuji a book left by Yuki which
contains research on the body and the
Soul also we noted in one of the
previous theories that Yuji should be
able to use suk's curse techniques at
some point why does that matter well we
know that sua somehow learned how to
split his soul into cursed objects and
was also able to resist mjo's Soul
manipulation so after being Suk in his
vessel for quite some time and learning
about souls it's possible that eugi now
has some of those Soul related at ated
abilities and can use them to swap
bodies with other people this ability
could be a major turning point for the
plot of jiujitsu Kaizen as it may
finally allow Yuji to become strong
enough to face sugana nobata is alive
ever since chapter 125 noa's status in
the manga has been unknown is she dead
or is she alive well although many fans
already accepted that she's most likely
dead and won't be appearing in the story
anymore there are some things hinting
that she might actually be alive so as
you remember Novara was hit by Idol
Transfiguration which was time again
described as a technique that can't even
be cursed by reverse curse technique as
it literally changes your soul now if we
leave it at that we can say that yes
noata is 100% dead however after she
presumably dies this guy appears and
says that there's still a slight chance
she can be saved now the important thing
to note here is that we've never seen
this guy before this and he also never
appeared after this it's like he was
just created for this one specific scene
I mean if gay wanted to kill nbat he
could have just left her lying there and
her death would be confirmed but for for
some reason he went through the trouble
of creating a random character with a
random curse technique that just so
happens that it maybe can save no's life
for obvious reasons a lot of fans aren't
buying that and expect that noata will
soon return to the story and help
Eugene's final fight against suona
prison realm the prison realm is a
special grade cursed object that has the
power to seal anyone inside it no matter
how strong they are we've seen it in
action during Shia arc when kinjaku
managed to seal Gojo who's known to be
the strongest jiujitsu sorcerer in the
current ERA Gojo eventually managed to
come out of the prison realm with the
help of Hana but now that it's empty
again there's a huge chance that it'll
play a massive role later on in the
series there were tons of theories about
who could get sealed next but the most
plausible one is that it'll be the king
of curses himself Rian sukuna I mean
considering suk's strength it's really
hard to imagine any of the sorcerers
actually posing a significant threat to
him so sealing him may end up being the
only viable option the only problem is
that they'll have to keep him within the
range for one full minute which won't be
easy but they may end up tricking him in
some way similar to how Kaku tricked
Gojo Ura um's Incarnation so what if
urum wasn't incarnated as summons the
other sorcerers and had instead been
alive for over a thousand years sounds
impossible right well let's go over some
things supporting this theory urum was
first seen in February while the
incarnated players awaken in late
October additionally all other
incarnated players are part of the
coling game while Ur um isn't it's also
evident that Kaku isn't a huge fan of
the curse user and urum wasn't even
needed NE necessarily for sukuna
Resurrection it just doesn't make any
sense why kinjaku would even incarnate
her so if Ur um isn't incarnated how did
she survived for over a thousand years
the best theory so far is that she
survived using her ice formation curse
technique you see gay always tries to
incorporate science into the techniques
he creates and since urum has an ice
technique it's possible that she can
slow down her aging cryogenically this
has already been proven theoretically
possible by science so it would make
sense that Uno has frozen herself in
order to survive patiently awaiting
suk's rebirth only three more stages are
left to cover and let's kick off the
next stage with this insane theory about
kaku's new body we already discussed how
Novara is most likely dead however since
mjo killed her by manipulating her soul
physically her body should be in pretty
good shape this is why some fans believe
that Kaku will eventually swap bodies
with her to further torment Yuji and use
her straw doll technique undeniably poor
Yuji is face the worst kind of emotional
damage in the anime and it doesn't seem
like it'll be ending anytime soon
although this theory is really unlikely
to actually happen you have to agree
that it would be really cool to see evil
noada in action tenen secret tenen is
one of the oldest Sorcerers in the
jiujitsu Kaizen world and is known for
her immortality since the beginning of
the show tangan has always been shrouded
in mystery and very little was revealed
about her since the coling game began
many fans speculated that Tangen is
definitely hiding something and there's
a strong reason for that first of all it
seems like tangan is well acquainted
with Kaku and knows sua as well one time
kinjaku even commented on how tangan
seeming l wants to look like suca
there's a popular theory that tangan and
kinjaku have known each other for quite
a long time and that they came up with
the concept for the cing game years ago
if I had to guess the two probably
worked together around 1 thousand years
ago during the hayan era and started the
coling game for some reason this would
also tie in well with the previous
theory about droo and the fact that
there was most likely another coling
game in the past so does this mean that
tenen is an accomplice of Kaku probably
not tenen might have had a completely
different plan for the calling game and
later on got betrayed by Kaku which
resulted in them drifting apart Kimo's
curse technique although Kimo's curse
technique was revealed in recent
chapters it was a big mystery in the
phanom for quite some time and there
were some great theories about it since
kosimo didn't want to use the technique
against anyone else except sukuna a lot
of fans believed that it was some kind
of All or Nothing attack that could
cause widespread destruction this was a
pretty good guess as we now know that
his technique is called the mythical
Beast Amber and it allows him to far
surpass his limits but it can only be
used once before his body crumbles
another great Theory focuses more on the
mythology part of kosimo as his
character was inspired by takauchi who
is known to be the God of Thunder and
the god of Swords this led many to
believe that his curse technique could
be summoning a single Divine sword or
even multiple swords some fans joked
about it and said that he's going to use
the unlimited blade works from the Fate
series Gojo will come back I know a lot
of you are probably tired of hearing
this Gojo is Alive stuff but let's go
over some hints and theories as to why
it may be true first of all it's
important to note that throughout the
show Gojo has always been associated
with Buddha take this scene for examp
example here Gojo pointed one of his
fingers up and one of his fingers down
this is the same exact thing Buddha did
when he was born another thing to note
is that Buddha also said the exact same
words Gojo says in this scene throughout
Heaven and Earth I alone am the honored
one okay but what does that have to do
with Gojo being alive well another thing
about Buddha is that he started his
journey to Enlightenment at the age of
29 and how old do you think Gojo is he's
exactly one day short of being 29 this
is why a lot of fans believe that these
parallels to Buddha suggest that Gojo
will go through some kind of spiritual
enlightenment and come back to the story
even stronger another thing supporting
this theory is found in Gojo's last
flashback here namami is saying that
everyone has a choice to go either south
or north if we look at everyone's
sitting positions we can see that namami
and Hiba are facing One Direction while
Gojo and ghetto are facing the other one
since Hanami and hibat are confirmed to
be dead this could mean that Gojo will
choose a different direction in survive
this could also make sense considering
that ghetto is also facing the same
direction as Gojo and we know that he's
still somewhat alive in kaku's current
body the last finger as you know even at
this point in the story sua ate only 19
of his fingers as he has no idea where
the last one is there were many theories
about it some say that Gojo has it and
others say that it's just lost somewhere
in the Jiu Kaizen World however the best
theory so far has to be that Yuji is
actually suk's last finger okay let me
explain we know that Kaka was in
possession of most of sua's fingers if
not all of them at some point in time we
also know that he experimented on Yuji
while was pregnant so what if kinjaku
somehow used the finger during his
experiments in order to make Yuji the
perfect vessel for sua when you think
about it we never really got the
specific answer as to why Yuji is able
to suppress suguna so well and this
Theory would explain it perfectly
another interesting thing is that while
talking to choso kju referred to Yuji as
it as if he was an object it's a term he
used specifically for Yuji and none of
his other creations like choso or his
brothers and lastly sua's original form
and Yuji both have pink hair this is a
very unique care color and could hint
towards the connection between the two
before we cover the last seventh stage
of the iceberg and some of the most
unhinged theories you ever heard let's
first cover the sixth stage which is
pretty crazy as well uta's real curse
technique UT utsu is a second-year
student at jiujitsu high and is the main
protagonist in the movie Zero there UTA
displayed his incredible abilities and
even Gojo said that UTA might surpass
him someday at the moment it's believed
that uta's curse technique is copying
and utilizing the techniques and
abilities of others but what if this
isn't the case you see there's a theory
that uda's real curse technique is the
ability to select a specific Target with
whom he shares a special bond he then
binds the target to an object that holds
sentimental value for them for example
in Ra's case it was a ring afterward the
strength of the curs spirit correlates
directly with how authentic the bond was
and the intensity of the love shared
according to this Theory UDA can also
use the curse technique of the spirit he
binds with and in Ra's case that ability
is copy this means that if UDA ever
binds with someone else he may get to
use a completely different curse
technique associated with the other
Spirit bizarre reverse curse techniques
only a handful of jiutu sorcerers can
use reverse curse techniques it's mainly
the ability used to heal human bodies
but if you're skilled enough you can
also combine the reverse curse technique
with your regular curse technique in
order to reverse its effects for example
when Gojo does this his blue technique
becomes red which is a color opposite to
Blue when Kaku uses it he can reverse
the effect of his anti-gravity system
and intensify the force of gravity
around him however one big problem with
this is how would this apply to some of
the other sorcerers take mayay for
example her curse technique is called
bird manipulation and it allows her to
control crows so what would the reversal
of this technique look like do Pros get
to control her what about tenen
immortality technique does he just die
if he tries to use It reversed anyway
it's quite obvious that this system
doesn't work with a majority of the
curse techniques in the series so I
guess some characters will just never
unlock this ability the gsha doo Theory
at the end of chapter 170 we can see
mum's domain expansion Chimera shadow
Garden looking like two bones of the
vertebrae since mum's domain is still
incomplete could it be that this base
will eventually grow into something
bigger well a lot of fans believe that
the Bones from aum's domain will create
a huge skeleton creature called
gashadokuro and here's why the zening
family is a descendant of one of the
three great vengeful spirits of Japan
tyan no masakado whose daughter was able
to summon Spirits the daughter could
also summon gashadokuro from the shadows
and had the ability to summon an army of
frogs and snakes sounds pretty familiar
right mumi has the exact same ability
what's more in episode 9 of the show mjo
can be seen reading a book while talking
to June if we zoom into this exact page
you can see that gashadokuro is
Illustrated in his book The Specific
scene only appears in the anime and it
was personally supervised by gig 2 I
mean out of thousands of monsters from
Japanese mythology gay could have
included on these Pages he intentionally
decided to include gashadokuro if this
isn't foreshadowing I don't know what is
and finally the seventh stage of the
iceberg I hope you're ready because some
the upcoming theories are so ridiculous
and bizarre that they'll literally blow
your mind ra is not ra okay so this is a
pretty unhinged one so you may have
noticed that the current RA in the manga
and ra from jiujitsu kaisen movie Zero
look a bit different now instead of just
accepting that this is a design change
some fans came up with some crazy
theories explaining R's different design
so you all remember how at the end of
the movie UDA lifted Ra's curse finally
setting her free some people believe
that ra died at that moment and Utah
couldn't use her powers anymore later
later on when UDA went to Africa to
train with Miguel during season 1 he
accidentally cursed another girl and
ended up with a completely new cursed
spirit this would explain why Ra's
design is different now as it's not ra
it's a completely different girl suk's
domain is a nuclear bomb one of the jjk
fans on Reddit noticed something
interesting when comparing nuclear bombs
to sua's domain expansion apparently
some of the smaller nuclear bombs like
those used in World War 2 have an
instant vaporization radius of around a
few hundred M this is really similar to
the range of sugan's mevolent Shrine
which is 200 M the shock wave of a
nuclear blast immediately damages
everything it comes into contact with
same as sua's technique dismantle which
immediately Cuts everything inside the
domain and lastly the radiation wave of
a nuclear blast destroys all living
things at a molecular level tearing them
apart piece by piece which is really
similar to how cleave Cuts all living
things inside the domain tearing them
apart looking at these facts it's most
likely that gay partly used the nuclear
bomb as inspiration when coming up with
sua's abilities the useless miwa there's
an ongoing gag in the show about miwa
one of the seconde students being
completely useless she even constantly
says it herself this is why there's a
theory that she'll actually play a big
part at some point in the story and
surprise everyone there's absolutely
nothing supporting this but everything's
possible I guess sua's past life due to
his cleave and dismantle ability some
fans speculated that sukuna was a chef
in his past life most of his attacks are
similar to cutting with a knife and the
fact that he can use fire techniques
further adds to this Theory as it would
probably help him with cooking also we
know Ura um was Suk kuna's subordinate
during the hyan era so maybe she was his
cooking assistant I mean there was no
Refrigeration back then so it's possible
that UDA um used her ice curse technique
to keep ingredients Frozen but if you're
interested in what happened to sua after
he stopped being a chef you can click
here next where we explained all of his
forms in Jutsu Kaizen